alors c'est en mars que la vie de
Natalie Portman s'est effondrée
apparemment l'actrice a pris son mari
depuis 2012 j'ai perdu ses deux enfants
avaient une liaison avec une autre femme
et il a sublime Natalie Portman il
s'attendait pas du tout on apprend
qu'elle aurait dû partir se mettre au
vert à la campagne chez des amis c'est
le temps de reprendre ses esprits mais
après elle a préféré revenir à Paris
parce qu'on avait vu aussi officiel de
Cannes et là elle est là sur Paris en ce
moment
au match effectivement la semaine
dernière alors comprenez-vous avant de
donner la parole à Florian parce que
Florian maîtrise parfaitement le dossier
je sais que tu as les réponses mais je
préfère que les chroniqueurs réagissent
aussi un peu d'abord comprenez-vous
qu'on puisse tromper Nathalie portable
est très belle elle est pas trompable
c'est vrai c'est c'est
un racisme de base c'est mais il faut
revoir le film trop belle pour toi
elle est intelligente est intelligente
elle travaille elle gagne des sous et en
France est-ce que justement s'ils
étaient retournés aux États-Unis lui il
a fait l'effort parce que elle ne
supportait pas la vie à Paris ne
supporte pas
et lui il a voulu revenir à Paris où
était sa carrière et elle elle a
manifestement là il y a un gros souci et
alors maintenant on dit qu'il se qui
sont au bord de la rupture c'est pour ça
que Paris Match qui sort aujourd'hui à
l'humain contre feu et montre tout leur
quotidien là et où il est appelé la
question de rupture
il est sorti pardon jeudi oui c'est très
long quand tu parles c'est bien dis-moi
quand tu as une femme trompée trop que
ça fait plaisir que quand les médias
s'en emparent et que tu vois dans la
presse que tu es trompé
mais que le monde entier ça je sens une
autre m'a demandé à Valérie trayerweiler
comment elle l'a véculé sur le sur
l'histoire non mais en fait quand il est
venu lui il a il a gagné le poste de la
direction de l'Opéra de Paris et au même
moment en fait il y a eu l'affaire avec
Galliano John Galliano ou voilà bon il y
a eu des insultes antisémite etc et en
fait elle a fait un peu un amalgame déjà
elle aimait pas trop la France elle
aimait pas trop Paris et elle lui a dit
bah la France en fait elle a fait une
généralité elle a dit la France est
antisémite
voilà et elle est rentrée aux États-Unis
donc tu as eu déjà entre une sorte de
premier schisme on va dire à ce
moment-là je crois qu'il y a une
question de racisme comme ça
vous êtes les enfants
vous êtes des meubles bien sûr il a
couché avec une meuf ah ouais il y a 10
ans
et elle a déclaré effectivement à la
presse qu'elle quittait la France parce
qu'elle considérait que la France était
comme ça oui c'est un couple comme tout
le monde c'est une histoire de cul voilà
il a eu des attirance pour une autre
fille comme ça arrive dans tous les
couples et ils s'en remettront si il
s'aime voilà tu peux tous les coups pour
vécu des tromperies etc si tu t'aimes tu
as envie de sauver ton couple tu le
sauves si tu as pas envie tu penses
prétexte là mais faut pas aller chercher
des trucs il a rencontré nana ils sont
plus ils ont couché ensemble mais je me
retourne maintenant vers Florian qui lui
il détient les sources il est au courant
de tous les magazines people de tout ce
qui est sorti et tu vas nous raconter
c'est un vrai journaliste exactement
exactement moi je suis pas journaliste
alors je peux le dire déjà on va on va
couper quoi tout ce qu'on dit depuis
tout à l'heure leur coupe va très bien
donc effectivement il y a eu un papier
qui est sorti 10 ans que il était allé
voir ailleurs
par image explique le contraire public
qui est sorti hier avec des informations
exclusives révélant que le couple le
lendemain du papier qui est sorti la
semaine dernière est à l'aise balader à
Aubervilliers main dans la main pour une
je crois que c'était la présentation du
nouveau projet de de Benjamin Millepied
oui Aubervilliers tout à fait donc voilà
donc ils vont ils vont très bien ils ont
des projets ensemble on parlait de Paris
soit disant elle aime pas les français
elle aime pas parler etc ils viennent se
réinstaller à Paris notamment parce que
Benjamin millepie à 1000 projets ici ça
y est il lance comme il avait lancé à
Los Angeles exactement sur les
Hauts-de-Seine tout à fait il va prendre
donc en gros entre ça va très bien
ensuite ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est
qui ce murmure dans leur entourage que
bah le petit coup de canif dans le
d'une infidélité ou d'une année proche
entre particuliers les sentiments et le
corps certes tu peux tromper sans que ça
soit tu continues à aimer ta chérie
dire Jean-Michel j'étais sûr qu'elle
allait dire ça tu l'as pas tort
Jean-Michel Déborah j'ai mené ma petite
enquête et j'ai contacté un ami de cette
fameuse Camille Étienne qui est
l'activiste écologiste avec qui serait
donc la nouvelle et effectivement il y a
eu en tout cas cette source très proche
d'elle m'a dit qu'il y avait une
histoire il y a eu papa dans maman quoi
est-ce que Nathalie Portman le savait et
la validé c'est autre chose mais en tout
cas il y aurait eu
fricoti fricotta quoi ah oui c'est plus
mignon tu as raison
que moi tu as raison
est-ce que j'ai le droit de vous dire
que même si on parle d'un couple libre
en attendant c'est elle qui a été
humiliée publiquement et pardon mais
Benjamin mille-pattes personne
[Applaudissements]
c'est un mec remarquable un grand
monsieur qui s'occupe des autres
Benjamin mille pieds il sera le film
je termine juste il était connu dans son
milieu mais c'est pas connu mondialement
comme il est dorénavant grâce à elle il
était pas trop d'opération
[Musique]
alors que lui c'est l'un des plus grands
chorégraphes au monde
de dénigrer l'un contre l'autre dans son
milieu il est et c'est lui qui l'a
éliminé là et elle elle est très connue
bah oui parce que c'est lui que les
photos ont chopé bah oui une semaine
plutôt à un autre endroit ça aurait été
l'inverse en revanche ce qui est vrai
Florian tu as raison mais ce qui est
vrai c'est que profondément elle elle
adore Los Angeles et que lui déteste Los
Angeles c'est pour ça qu'il a rapatrier
en France et on peut le comprendre des
Américains atteignaient leur pelouse
pour qu'elle l'air verte lui c'est pour
lui c'était le summum de l'horreur alors
moi je voudrais l'expert matrimonial
monsieur Candeloro bah moi je suis
embêté parce que j'ai pas mis ça dans le
contrat de mariage
tromperie pas d'accord voilà c'est que
la presse s'en est mêlée ça foutu le
bordel n'est pas sûr en tout cas d'après
notre ami Florian tout va bien etc moi
je sais qu'ils ont cherché une maison au
Pilat sur mer figure-toi c'est vrai
ouais
parce que je les ai croisé des photos
alors j'ai fait une j'ai fait une
tronche c'était le vendeur immobilier
non c'est vrai j'ai fait une drôle de
tête tu sais non je m'a fait la photo
genre je suis tombé sur eux et moi
j'allais au restaurant à côté ils
étaient dans la rue il cherchait les
maisons tu sais que c'est vraiment calme
c'est des maisons un peu bascolandaises
chez nous au Pyla-sur-Mer et il est
adorable tout mignon là récemment